et cette piqûre obligatoire c'est un
véritable chamboulement pour bon nombre
de professions mais qu'en pensent les
français nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de stéphane sabatier sapeurs
pompiers volontaires pour protester
contre l'obligation vaccinale ce père de
famille a même entamé une grève de la
faim sur le toit de sa caserne avant que
le gign n'intervienne pour le faire
descendre un reportage signé luca léger
avant de retrouver nos invités
nous sommes à oizon ville en
eure-et-loir je me trouve avec monsieur
sabatier pompiers qui ne veut pas de la
vaccination bonjour monsieur sabatier
merci de nous recevoir chez vous tout
simplement vous pouvez m'expliquer
depuis combien de temps vous êtes
pompiers et pourquoi ça a été la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase bah
moi je suis pompier depuis l'âge de 16
ans j'ai des pompiers ici
je suis rentré à 20 ans quand un pompier
de paris je suis retraité des pompiers
de paris et depuis dix ans j'étais je
suis pompier volontaire à la caserne
nabli dans le 78 juste à côté à partir
du 15 septembre comme je veux pas vers
vacciner bas je serai plus pompier mon
métier et mon expérience tient une deux
injections pourquoi vous avez autant de
packs d'eau devant chez vous j'ai décidé
de faire un jeune de contester une grève
de la faim alors une grève de la faim
sur le toit de la caserne j'ai pas dormi
de la nuit dont je suis resté là haut
pour fall est monté sur le toit toutes
les pancartes les le tout matériel les
tentes et tout j'étais très bien
installé un j'aurais pu rester très très
longtemps alors malheureusement j'ai
prévenu rend très honnêtement j'ai
contacté la direction qui elle est
obligée en fait malema direction on est
obligé de suivre la loi c'est clair et
je leur en veux pas
mais mon erreur c'est que je les ai
prévenus est pas allé par les médias ce
sera peut-être passées différemment je
sais pas voilà je vous avais eu affaire
aux gendarmes oui le gène est venu pour
négocier avec moi pour me revois facture
descendent
moi je suis pas un bon dit non plus j'ai
des enfants
vis-à-vis des enfants finir en garde à
vue c'était moyen donc là ils m'ont
expliqué que comme j'ai été
pacifistes et ben du coup bah là
vers ie aucune aucune charge contre moi
en fait mon erreur c'est que les médias
n'étaient pas sur place parce qu'ils ont
bouclé tout là toute la canalise accès à
la caserne pour pas qu'il y ait des
images en fait moi
ça c'était ma première médaille pour
acte de courage et dévouement celle-ci
jeté pour un feu voilà un feu de un feu
l'hôpital fernand widal mais celle-ci en
fait c'est le feu
la rue de provence le feu plus meurtrier
après la libération de paris est-ce que
c'est dur d'envisager de quitter cette
profession que vous avez exercé pendant
des décennies avant dans 30 ans en fait
forcément ça fait une deuxième sim
deuxième famille le
les pompiers
compass 72 heures d'affilée avec des
collègues ça il ya des affinités c'est
ma deuxième famille moi ma famille je la
quittais je retrouve une deuxième là bas
en tant que pompier c'est comme ça alors
dans ma tête c'est très clair je serai
jamais plus longue et voilà j'ai fait le
deuil de cette triste mais c'est comme
ça et financièrement vous allez vous en
sortir comment alors moi concrètement
jeu comme j'étais pompier volontaire et
j'avais ma retraite des pompiers de
paris 891 euros pour 10 80 pompiers de
paris est en fête avec ma jolie décidé
avec ma femme d'être comme femmes
travaillent des pères au foyer en fait
donc depuis dix ans je suis père au
foyer je m'occupe des deux enfants dans
les sorties scolaires jeu le coach coach
de balles de deux équipes et
ben je faisais 1000 euros voilà j'ai
gravées à gagner 1000 euros en étant
prenait en moyenne 1000 euros les mille
euros c'est bah c'est simplement la
somme qui sort tous les mois pour les
études de notre regard c'est tout donc
on allait sortir et retrouver un certain
équilibre donc je suis pas feignant je
retrouve un travail ça c'est sûr mais
milieu où vous les retrouvez voilà il ya
pas de problème mais voilà c'est ça tous
voient toute notre vie assez compte de
rien en fait
vous m'avez dit que le fait qu'on incite
vos enfants à se faire vacciner ça avait
été un déclic dans votre votre
motivation est ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer un peu en détail ce qui
s'est passé mes trois enfants sont
passés en sélection handball c'est à
dire qu'ils sont ils font partie des
meilleurs joueurs du département lui est
toujours en sélection de balle et
en sélection départementale pardon et
lui en plus de ça il était sélectionné
pour entrer au centre d'entraînement
départemental des antiquités sont son
collège de deux secteurs pour partir à
chartres en tant que à l'internât donc à
présent à partir d'un internat pour
pouvoir bas son rêve c'est de venir en
valeur et l'a donc du coup deux jours de
la rentrée on nous a appelés en nous
disant à partir du 30 septembre votre
fils
faux faux faux savoir si les vaccinés ou
si l'art à savoir si l'impasse à luther
est comme vous la clinique on nous a dit
fo qui quitte la sélection donc là on a
pris la décision de le remettre dans son
collège alors le gamin
voilà c'est on applaudit sion avec lui
le petit il il veut pas s'arrêter il n'y
a pas envie pour une population qui est
pas touchée donc c'est vraiment une
décision politique qui a vraiment
bouleversé votre vie assez vraiment où
il annonce du monsieur le président a
bouleversé nos dit totalement totalement
que ce soit pour notre mais de mon
métier ou pour mes gamins pour pour
toute la famille pour là on a tous
arrêtés plus ou moins long pour
l'instant autant qu'on peut faire les
tests on joue et le jour on pourra plus
faire était son propre jeu dans l'offre
politique qu'on est déjà en train de vie
n'est pour la présidentielle qui arrive
est ce que vous trouvez que sur le pass
sanitaire il ya un vrai débat moi ce que
je veux c'est qu'il y ait un candidat
qui bat qu'ils
nous fassent ogba pour moi pour mes
gamins c'est une phase sauter le pas
sanitaires simplement c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça